demain
[Musique]
tout
mais bonjour c'est vous komoé la réunion
oui j'étais en plein exercice physique
aujourd'hui on le monte à mahé dauger
profiter de l'air frais pourquoi nous
montée envahie dès aujourd'hui on va
voir jennifer qui va nous parler de
spiruline alors la spiruline c'est quoi
sinon comment est ce qu'il revienne
c'est pourquoi
et bien vous allez savoir si vous me
suivez
et vous allez me suivre vous êtes
obligés de monsieur aller plus vite vous
voulez allez on y va parce que new line
avec jennifer c'est parti
[Musique]
à rien
ces données là bonjour l'univers
courvalet ça va ça va bien venu à qui
france merci 10 mois est paré et paris
tu fais la spiruline de paris donc cool
j - petit peu déjà nine donc on est à la
petite france dans les eaux du saint pol
guillaume et on est dans notre sert avec
nos bassins spiruline l'aspirine il
ouvre donc en fait la rue l'insee ce
espèce de liquide verdâtre offre donc
c'est de l'eau avec la turdine titan
suspension puisqu'il est une algue
c'est un milieu de son maître donc c'est
une aile d'un suspension tout simplement
c'est pour ça que ça cette espèce de dos
verdâtre cette culture en fait destiné à
quoi est-ce que c'est médicinales alors
médicinales c'est être un bien grand mot
mais c'est vrai ça a quand même beaucoup
de vertus de curling
donc sachant quand même que la seiche le
père un petit peu de ses propriétés même
si comme nous en sélectionnons qui n'est
pas pasteurisé donc le fait de sécher sa
terre quand même un petit peu de cette
propriété au niveau des vitamines
nous on essaie d'orienter notre
clientèle plutôt vers la cuisine fraîche
ou congelée ou fréchette du miel donc
c'est vrai que toutes les personnes qui
les consomment en général c'est soit
parce que c'est long des carences les
les femmes après l'accouchement souvent
des tout de faire assez bas donc à ce
que rien n'est très riche en fer ça
remonte très rapidement les taux de fer
les personnes fatiguées les sportifs
utilisent aussi beaucoup après on a
aussi décrit gens qui ne mangent ni
viande et poisson en rien d' animal dont
qui compense avec l'aspirine c'est très
riche en protéines
mais de là à dire que c'est vraiment un
faux du mime finale ou un produit
miracle non j'irai pas jusque là quoi ça
va aider l'organisme
ça va renforcer voilà ça va renforcer
l'organisme ça va l'aider mais c'est pas
non plus il faut pas en attendre non
plus des miracles
bon quand même mais c'est souvent quand
même il faut donner ça ou alors voilà on
en semences en fait on sait on remplit
quand on fait un bassin neuf candidats
un premier bassin
donc on remplit d'eau en salle et
ensuite on en semences la pile le bassin
tout simplement c'est à dire qu'on a au
fond d'la des piscines avec le milieu de
culture qu'on garde en réserve c'est
notre stock notre sécurité
donc c'est la souche en fait tu
récupères ça comment donc
donc en fait la pompe voilà là où il va
amener le milieu et ça m'a décembre
parce que tu sais quoi
on va lancer je pense qu'on va regarder
tout ça imaginons qu'une regardez moi
j'ai envie d'apprendre ça l'accord
hockey
et cela ça sonne à fond
donc là en fait de programmateur pour
les fesses ah ouais d'accord
[Musique]
suis parti maintenant allez on va dire
alors toi par jour par semaine ici alors
tous les jours la cidrerie c'est sur les
jours après au niveau de la récolte
s'est lancée là où on passe aux six de
ses entretiens ça va relativement rapide
ça peut prendre deux ou trois heures
nettoyer les bassins vérifier que son
art se répondent c'est ça le plus long
c'est la récolte
vous parlez de n'ouvrir la série gines
et une oui tu nourris avec pourquoi pas
fait cela nourrit avec des minéraux avec
des minéraux d'accord ok elle bénéficie
la spiruline
non c'est pas les passants a besoin de
têtes guyane pas besoin de tout ça non
c'est bon ça mon salon des minéraux pas
manger son repas de suite dit oui dans
ses pas
linden lab les ballets bobos mais banal
you might et itamar il a compris qu on
arrêter larry minutes voile alors là
c'est en fait une petite récolte donc on
espérait que parent minutes
donc ça c'est une récolte destinée à la
crème fraîche
donc ça va laisser jouer en fait au fur
et à mesure ça va être de plus en plus
compacts et tu fais combien de deux
récoltes par jour alors nous on fait une
récolte ça dépend une à deux récoltes
par semaine c'est vrai qu'il nous a
réveillés au départ quand on a commencé
la série on faisait plus rétro lancer
nico ce n'est de trois jours et en fait
ça s'avérait beaucoup trop important par
rapport à la productivité la pioline ici
donc maintenant on fait une récolte par
semaine voire une récolte
les pompiers l'ont senti très vite dix
mois la voilà la particularité en fait 2
donc notre syrie n'est produite
localement 30 sans senna transfert d'une
sèche on est les seuls sur l'île à ne
pas la pastore
il faut savoir que la pasteurisation en
fait se fait plus pour un problème de
conservation comme notre circuit c'est
un circuit très court
c'est à dire qu'on récolte on la récolte
aujourd'hui on est jeudi à les
commercialiser ce week-end
donc on n'a pas besoin d'une
conservation importante
et puis le fait de pasteuriser aussi ça
fait perdre beaucoup de beaucoup de
vitamines voilà beaucoup de propriétés à
la spiruline donc nous c'est un choix
qu'on a c'est un certain temps qu'on a
c'est qu'on assume donc on ne peut pas
stories pas notre spiruline est pour la
seconde et une fraîche dalgaard la
totalité de ses vertus donc la nôtre
notre studio line qui a été relancé et
goûter et donc on va presser devant la
presse me voilà
cole - la ville avait réellement soleil
qaïda tué mes pommes l'apei décor
obama à notre niveau en tout cas ça
reste remarquer la lettre
l'appel à projets
l'oeil et formera ses décors
donne levé il est là
je suis en train de devenir un
spécialiste spiruline bien grâce à vous
alors donc voila tu après celle où est
enlevé et maintenant on fait quoi
cela en fait on va descendre on va
descendre sur gonesse là où en est notre
laboratoire
au revoir la conditionner à goodwwod
meubles on m'appelle le goûteur et de
spiruline paraissait très bon petit bout
mais c'est pas sympa pour du tout c'est
un peu la texture du beurre presque aux
fesses de trême comme ça qui me rappelle
celle de schumi sur une tartine et c'est
bon à les entendre
[Musique]
on sort du magot on arrive à bois de
nèfles et on va regarder un petit peu
comment tout ça se transformer en
connaître plus sur la spiruline ne vaut
mieux qu'un oui entrée voilà donc la ses
laboratoires
donc en fait c'est ici qu'on ramène la
figurine qui a été pressé et donc pas la
condition c'est les spaghettis soit on
sait comment ça sert ce matin en fait
d'aspyr d'une fraîche avec du miel c'est
un laboratoire inox qui a été car les
dons qui se mordent mais c'est vrai que
je montrerai pas le processus en fait
c'est une machine spécifique
donc au final ce que ça va donner
c'est ça voilà on va remplir des jours
dans cette banque au bond dans les
actuelles il prêche il est lancé avec du
miel et avec du moringa leviel bio dont
il vient de saint-philippe dangereux
voilà donc en forme on mélange avec un
certain pourcentage de ski robin et donc
au final je vais vous faire goûter ce
que ça donne donc ça a toujours sa
couleur verte
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
la couleur du club seulement 900 pages
dessus après c'est vrai que le moringa
qui est plus particulier au niveau du
goût c'est plus r2 c'est vraiment pour
moi une stèle du beurre oui voilà c'est
pas c'est pas très compact ne sais pas
trop liquide non plus
[Musique]
alors maintenant que tu m'as tout
montrer et que j'ai goûté est un produit
qui d'ailleurs m'a étonné parce que
franchement je ne m'y attendais pas
avoir un bout aussi prononcée soit en
mieux avec la cuma a tellement de
possibilités avec ce produit et moi je
veux tout savoir de toi ma chère mais en
fait non on est arrivé à la réunion il
ya un peu plus de 30 ans un peu par
hasard et on a on a eu l'opportunité de
reprendre l'exploitation de ces robes de
monsieur ousmane non ils seront là c'est
qu'on a gardé pendant plus de 20 ans
puis on a réussi on est passé à autre
chose donc la maintenance et de la
tomate ancien nom c'est d'aspirine ont
fait la culture hydroponique en ester en
sac et en fait on est des touche-à-tout
comme beaucoup d'investisseurs la
réunion on n'a pas le choix ça donc on
est sur des petits les sites de niche
chaque fois mais on aime ce qu'on fait
on essaye d'en vivre
c'est pas toujours évident mais bon
voilà c'est comme ça 0 il ya débat 2006
qui croient convaincu le toit lui même
coup si l'étudiant au revoir ça a été un
plaisir et puis on retrouve à l'espagne
mardi
donc je vous laisse sur une magnifique
vue de la ville du port
moi je suis totalement en forme je vais
m'en jahier après avoir pris des ti-culs
est plus rude in là je sens que je vais
donner à 3,5 la ce est obligé je vous
dis tout simplement aurevoir à la
prochaine et d'oublier un truc
au fait on n'est vraiment pas sorti de
l'auberge mais je vous l'assuré
mais alors pas du tout non mais sérieux
monsieur sommes pas sortis de l'auberge
la pastille du tout salut
[Musique]